across the country people are looking
for justice
our leaders tell us that only criminals
are punished and imprisoned civil rights
are protected and all people are treated
with dignity but that isn't our reality
our criminal justice system needs fixing
it's at the root of many problems we
face today
poverty broken families and a broken
economy so aj+ is spending the next few
weeks exploring stories about the US
justice system from the expansion of our
prisons 2.2 million people are
imprisoned in the u.s. more than in any
country in the world to policies that
push the most vulnerable children out of
school the school to Prison Pipeline
it's a term that describes how American
kids get pushed out of public schools
and into the juvenile and criminal
justice systems to life after prison the
impact of leaving with a felony as
opposed to adjudication just really set
up young
or recycling into the system and we're
speaking to activists who are trying to
create change when a person is applying
for a job now it's typical for there to
be a box that says have you ever been
convicted of a felony well there's been
a movement to you rather keep that box
to eliminate that box watch aj+ as we
share stories of what justice and
injustice actually look like to the
people on the other side of the system